dear Jake Paul there's been a lot of
controversy lately surrounding hue and
price come and a handful of other
creators promoting a website called
mystery brand but this video will be a
bit different for those who don't know
mystery brand is a website where you can
pay money anywhere between a few dollars
to hundreds of dollars to open up a
digital box and potentially win prizes
the more expensive the box the higher
the potential rewards with some prizes
allegedly being worth millions of
dollars and others being worth next to
nothing of course this is just a version
of a gambling website the controversy
being that you Jake and other youtubers
promoting this have extremely young
audiences look I'll jump right to the
point because other videos have already
done a good job at calling you out and
whistleblowing the fishy aspects of the
entire situation with mystery band so
here's the thing
addiction is awful in many instances of
drug abuse when you first use them you
get a big dopamine kick out of them
which is why they're so addictive but
with long term use your brain and body
just get used to it often your brain
will create more receptors as a response
which means you need to take more to
elicit the same feeling this can lead to
a loss of control and compulsive
behavior despite any negative
consequences it also means that when you
stop taking the drug you likely
experience withdrawal symptoms and all
of this can contribute to life long
neuroplastic changes in the brain
the thing is in 2013 the American
Psychiatric Association changed gambling
addiction from an impulse control
disorder to the substance-related and
addictive disorder category now I didn't
expect you to know that I didn't either
but what it means is that gambling
disorders are now considered to be much
more similar to alcohol and drug
addictions than to other disorders
here's a picture of a brain from
somebody winning a game of chance and
another where they almost win they're
really similar in both situations a
dopamine reward is triggered making the
experience enjoyable and ultimately
making your body want it again
sound familiar well just like drugs a
gambling addiction can do the exact same
thing the more you do it the more you
need to do it the dopamine literally
changes your brain cells in order to
drive you to perform this act again in
the future
it rewires your brain except unlike
drugs even when you don't get the
desired outcome gambling can still
trigger that feedback loop as seen in
the brain scans studies also show a
similar impairment of brain regions and
gamblers to people with drug dependence
specifically there is a degradation of
white matter and changes to regions of
the brain that control emotional
processing attention and decision-making
regions that are still developing in
teen years now none of this is to say
that people can't gamble responsibly and
have some harmless fun and while some
people are at high risk for addiction
many are not but part of the reason most
all governments restrict the age of
gambling much like alcohol and
recreational drugs is because of the
severe consequences it can have on young
people and their developing minds it's
not just irresponsible because we
arbitrarily say it is it's irresponsible
because it can have real long-term
physiological and psychological impacts
on young people especially while their
brains are still forming in fact teens
are the most likely group to become
addicted to gambling because there's a
much stronger reaction in the habit
region of the brain after they receive a
reward their prefrontal cortex
responsible for planning ahead and
assessing risk is also not fully formed
which is why teens are more likely to
partake in high-risk behaviors not to
mention gambling addictions usually
start at a young age even though it's
typically illegal for them to
participate in fact mystery brands own
website says the use of the services of
the website is strictly prohibited for
persons under 13 or persons not reached
the age of majority the age of majority
in most places is actually 18 and given
that your audience and many others
advertising this is typically much
younger than that I'm surprised this
isn't considered a violation of not only
their own terms
YouTube's as well YouTube's guidelines
state that we don't allow certain kinds
of gambling related advertising gambling
ads must have a landing page that
displays information about responsible
gambling and never target minors yet
mystery brand has no such landing page
and you yourself have explicitly said
your audience is made up of primarily
minors if my audience is definitely
younger I'd say it's like eight years
old so like 16 years old so that's where
I try to like cater the content towards
YouTube also basically says the same
thing for alcohol related ads would you
promote alcohol consumption as
emphatically to your audience
again it's not that it's inherently
wrong but not your audience by your own
admission is much much younger I don't
want to make it sound like branded
integrations is the problem we also rely
heavily on sponsors but given this type
of integration is specifically called
out in YouTube's Terms and by mystery
brands own legal articles it seems
awfully suspect that they would come
directly to you and pay you to advertise
it should you have known all this no but
now you do and maybe you'd say that's
mystery brands issue not yours but just
remember that studies have shown the
impact of YouTube celebrities like you
on young people 63% of kids aged 13 to
24 said that they would try a brand or
product recommended by a YouTube content
creator which is 15% higher than the
influence of even TV and movie stars you
can and should probably do something
about that a simple start would be to
just take the video down like others
have so it doesn't influence any more
people thanks for watching and
considering this jake-o also we don't
actually know dick Paul so if you guys
want to send this to him for a little
education that'd be swell and subscribe
for more weekly science videos